Throughout the debut season of "1883," Isabel
May's character Elsa Dutton serves as one
of the show's biggest cornerstones.
Not only does the young Dutton ancestor quickly
establish herself as a key protagonist in
the "Yellowstone" prequel spin-off, but she
also provides the narration for the Taylor
Sheridan-created show.
One of the most intriguing qualities about
Elsa is her hardiness and her independence
— traits handed down from her parents, James
and Margaret Dutton, played by Tim McGraw
and Faith Hill.
Throughout Season 1 of "1883," Elsa often
finds herself in some of the show's toughest
situations as she, her family, and other settlers
made their way from Texas to Oregon in hopes
of a new life.
Through every potentially disastrous or fatal
encounter, the Duttons pulled through as a
family unit, with Elsa providing audiences
a unique window in their mental and emotional
headspace.
Looking back, it's easy to pick out several
different instances and moments from "1883"
where fans were genuinely upset or affected
by what Elsa was going through.
However, there's one scene in particular that
firmly stands out above the rest, with some
viewers calling it "almost unbearable" to
watch.
The scene in question comes in the final moments
of the show's season finale.
Elsa, is preparing to say her final goodbyes
as her condition has become increasingly worse.
What happens next is a moment that "1883"
and "Yellowstone" fans will likely never forget.
A majority of the finale episode is spent
trying to get her the medical care Elsa desperately
needs, even though it's clear the wound is
too severe; she's not long for this world.
A heartbreaking decision is made: James Dutton
will travel with Elsa and wherever the pair
stop to rest is the place where the Dutton
patriarch will lay down roots for his family's
new homestead.
During Elsa's final moments, James takes his
daughter to an open area and they rest by
a very specific tree — a tree that "Yellowstone"
fans quickly recognized.
She tells her father,
"This is the spot.
Let's just sit here.
Rest for a bit."
It's a poignant moment and one that's also
extremely heartbreaking, to the point where
viewers were genuinely upset and angry with
Paramount for airing it.
Elsa's death helps set up the backstory for
how the Dutton family ranch came to settle
in Paradise Valley, Montana, the location
where the present-day Dutton family lives,
works, and schemes.
The untimely passing of James' eldest child
is unexpected and perhaps not the kind of
finale plot twist fans were hoping to see.
It feels like a cruel misdirect, having Elsa
taking on such an important position as a
narrator and becoming a central figure, only
to be wiped off the board by something as
treatable as an arrow wound (even by "1883"
standards).
And yet, there is something moving in knowing
that it is Elsa, a character audiences spend
so much time with in Season 1, who will be
the metaphorical foundation on which Dutton
Yellowstone Ranch is built.
Although it's clear to see how Elsa's death
actually served to move the plot of "1883,"
as well as the saga of the Dutton family,
forward, fans were not pleased to see the
beloved character (or actress Isabel May)
exit the show, especially in such a tragic
manner.
One user tweeted,
"Since Elsa died, I canceled."
Another expressed, quote, "I can't live without
her," posting a petition online to request
that Paramount Network bring May's character
back somehow.
Their disgust flowed over into a second tweet,
which included this observation:
"Elsa had to die because it explains how they
end up in Montana?
How stupid!"
Elsewhere on Twitter, one fan explained, quote
"It's just too heartbreaking," and another
said simply, "So many tears."
Over on YouTube, viewers were just as upset.
One user commented,
"That final scene was heartbreaking and almost
unbearable."
Another YouTuber remarked,
"Won't be the same without [Elsa].
I can now cancel Paramount+."
The death of Elsa was a moment that not only
weighed heavy on viewers but the actors as
well.
"1883" star Tim McGraw told Variety,
"We literally couldn't read [the final scripts]
to each other because [Faith Hill and I] were
crying so much.
I mean, ugly, boo-hoo crying.
I was a blubbering idiot."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Yellowstone
and 1883 are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.